Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome back to another edition of my mom plays Five Nights At Freddy's
This time, playing Five Nights At Freddy's 2. Do you know about this game?
Momiplier: I don't think so
It's a sequel to Five Nights At Freddy's 1, the one you played last year.
-Oh, yeah. I played last year.
Markiplier: Yeah, you're an expert at it
Momiplier: It was scary
Little bit. Not TOO bad.
-Do I have to go through that torture one more time?
No, no, no you have to go through DIFFERENT torture. See, this one's less scary than the other one.
-Really?
Yeah, it's more technically challenging but I think with your experience in the last one you're gonna be able to get into this one just fine.
-Hope so
Yeah okay, alright
So, put on the headphones.
-Oh, come on you're gonna mess up my hair?
No, no, no. Its fine, its like a hairband, it looks good on you,
-Looks good on me?
Yeah, looks good on you.
Okay so, get into position, and grab the mouse.
-Yeah, I'm going
Now, go to 'Custom Night.'
-This is not live right?
Huh?
-It's not live?
No, it's not live, no.
-Thank god.
So in this one you remember, do you remember these people? Say em with me-
-Freddy
Freddy
-Bonnie, Chica, Foxy.
Yeah, you remember them. Now that was the first game, that was just them
There's 6 more people in this one.
-Okay
Okay
Alright, so name them.
-It's a BB [Balloon Boy]
BB
-Tony [Toy] Freddy
Tony Freddy
-Tony Bonnie
Tony Bonnie
-Tony Chica
Tony Chica
-Mangle
Mangle
-Golden Freddy
Yeah, okay so
[Starts laughing] The tony, the tony, the tony uh, the tony [sips]
The tony ones, those are the ones you gotta watch out for, so
I'ma make this a little easier for you
I'm gonna set you off, cause if it was on 20,
20's the highest it'll go, that's the most difficult
But I want you to have a nice easy go of it
called the cupcake challenge.
-Oh, I...
Everyone, yeah everyone's on board, but everyone's at an easy level: at a 5. [5 is Medium Difficulty]
When you're ready, go for it.
-Okay, ready!
Ready
-Whatever I'm doing
Okay, so, in this one, it's a little bit different.
You remember where you have, like the, the, the, the ipad thing that you gotta slam up to your face
and you boop around on the cameras.
You remember that?
-Yeah I think so.
Okay you still have that. That's the white bar there, so hover over that, and click.
-Okay
Wait
Why doesn't that work?
Wait, go up.
And then go down?
There we go, okay.
Now see, you got all these cameras.
-Okay...
So if you look around- Uh oh! Camera 11!
Go there, click on that. Uh- it too late..
(bad music box music)
uhhhhhh
I-I kinda forgot to tell you
about that.
That's a very important factor.
(disgusted Momiplier)
-What was that?
That was uh, the puppet...
Okay, so,
alright, so, um
You need your coffee to be able to get through this one.
Go back, flip the, flip the thing.
Okay now go to camera 11.
-CAMERA 11!
Okay, now click and hold that.
-Okay, hold it!
-HOLD IT, HOLD IT
Yeah (x8)
-Winding up music box, YES I'M HOLDING (x2)
-WHAT IS GONNA HAPPEN? WHAT'S GONNA HAPPEN?
You're good. (X2)
That means it's good.
Now if you let go of that
-LET GO?
See how it clicks down, so you always gotta come
back to that music box, and try to wind it
-OHHHHHHHhhhhh...
It goes very quickly
-Now what do I need to do?
So wind it back up again!
because it's about to run out, see the little circle?
-Okay okay okay okay
Once thats down,
You can throw, throw the, throw the screen down
quickly
-Mhm
Throw the screen down, quickly!
-How?
There, okay
PUT IT BACK UP, PUT IT BACK UP
[Distressed Momiplier]
Awww... I forgot, wait it's not 'put it back up'. Is it 'put it back up'? I can't remember.
Is that the, is that the... [laughter]
-You, you're doing that- not- it's unintentionally right?
No no no, I'm not doing that.
-Why you keep..asking me to play this scary game all this.. last year
'Cause sometimes, families need... regularity! and (x3)
special occasions!
And there's a word for that, but I can't remember it (its tradition.)
right now, its the word for when families do stuff together
all the time!
and they call it the yearly thing! and they have the, like, commemorative moments where...
THEY HAVE THIS THING WHERE, YOU KNOW THEY DO THE, THINGS EVERY YEAR,
WHAT'S THE WORD FOR IT. THERE IS A WORD FOR IT!
WHEN THEY HAVE LIKE, ANNUAL... TRADITION!
-It's our tradition now?
...Yeesss.
-C'mon, oh click on here, c'mon wind wind wind wind wind wind!
-WIIIIIND
Alright, cool.
-Now what do I do?
Okay, now you look around, now
you see, that's your helmet
If there's a monster in your avenue, click on that.
Okay, now click back, er, um.
Now, okay now go to camera 11.
-11!
Click click hurry!
AHHHH!!
Alright see, when you open up your camera, it will open on the last thing you opened.
Right?
-Mhm
So you don't need to click camera 11 again,  so.
Click and hold and then
put it down,
Ah, alrigh- PUT IT BACK UP
-AAAAAAA [laughter]
(minigame opening static) (Momiplier Laughing)
You did it; hey look you got a minigame.
(stressed Mark)
-11. I know that!
-I'm gonna, I'm gonna wind this up by pushing this one.
okay, alright, okay
-NAH!
Now put the camera down
[unintelligible] Put that up,
Control [Ctrl] !
Turns on a light down your hallway.
-Oooh
So you wanna check the hallway
-OOOH! SOMETHING'S IN THERE
I saw it!
-I saw Freddy!
-This is much harder than the last one!.
-I swear
-like, 20/20
Okay, I'm gonna come clean.
I've been
You've technically been on whats called 'Custom Night'.
which is a lot harder.
-Oh no-one said that!
I'ma go easy on you
All you have to do is hit "new game,"
and we're gonna start from the beginning.
but I'm sorry that was just for a laugh.
-*deep sigh* I know there was up to something
-I didn't know that I was that bad
(counting camera numbers.)
-Nothing?
Here's a hint: you can use your flashlight in the cameras too.
-Okay (creeped out Momiplier)
-I  can see better. Oooooh
-Camera 8 has a dead body here. Two of em
-They are dead, right?
Well maybe, what if they're not dead?
-Three of them!
-I see Chica, Bonnie,
-What is this?
-Freddy?
Yeah, that's Freddy.
-They are dead
-They are really dead
-Should I go to other cameras too?
Yeah yeah
(counting camera numbers)
-Oooh, what is that?
AHH it's worms!
Warning: Your flashlight has a battery.
-Oh shoot
-I need to let go right?
-This, this is Freddy, right there
-So what should I do?
You should just...
-C'MON! Get outta here!
Be on the lookout
-Okay!
Watch that music box
*panicky Momiplier*
-C'mon!
Uh-huh
-C'mon! Wind up! Music, right?
-Oh, c'mon!
-C'mon what's gonna happen? How can I get away with this?
You can always go away to other places but you just have to come back at a regular interval
-Why?
Because if you don't, you'll die.
-Oh if I don't check on them they'll sneak on me?
Oh, oh, someone's on the loose.
Yeah, they'll sneak on you.
-So I have to sneak on them, right?
Yeah exactly.
-OOHH I got it, I got it
You gotta get the counters
-Come on! Come on! Come on!
I'll let ya in on a secret. If you go to camera 9..
'Kay. People are missing, right?
-Yeah
That means-
-Where are they?
Good question!
-Two of em are missing!
THERE'S ONE!
-What should I do?!
Flashlight!
[Startled Momiplier noises] -Yeah!
Yeah!
-I got you, Chica!
[Mark laughs]
Don't waste your battery
- Okay, what should I do?
Just make sure they don't get you
YOUR MUSIC BOX!
[more panicked noises]
-Oh yeah! Oh wind up!
[Mark laughing]
Get the heart pumping.
-Now, where should I go?
Wh- where's Bonnie?
-Bonnie was 9? Wasn't it? 9?
Where's Bonnie?
-Bonnie! Bonnie right here. No?
No, yeah! That's Bonnie!
-Oh, right here right here!
There's Bonnie! Okay where's Freddy?
-FREDDY?! Oh, I don't know!
Freddy's the blue one, right?!
-I don't know!
Where's Freddy?
-7... It-It's Chica is 7!
[Momiplier enters panic mode]
Use your flashlight!
-Oh flashlight!
There he is!
[Momiplier screams]
-Aahh! I gotcha! I gotcha!
Yeah, gotcha. Oh gotcha!
-Mmmmmm... Mommy's so fast
Oh yeah.
-Mommy's good. B)
-Oooh, you!
She's trying to get into the vent
-Thank you! Is that for me?
-Thank you, Chica! It's so sweet!
-I'll check on you later!
-See you later.
[Noises of panic]
-Wind up!
Very close!
But I'd watch camera 5... I think, I think Chica's trying to get close.
-5, 5, 5, 5! Okay! I gotcha!
-OHH!
Okay! She's there! Okay, alright.
-You're so cute. Hello!
Okay, put the camera down.
Okay big warning! She's on her way
-Okay, what should I do? What should I do?
Put your camera down!
-DOWN?! Why?!
-Down! Down!
Okay, now, she's gonna come out of that vent
-Right here???
That vent.
-Okay. [Panics]
So. Just...
[Momiplier panics more]
Uh oh, your music box.
-Oh oh oh!
11!
-11!
Wind!
-Wind!
Okay, now go back. I want you to go back and look at that vent!
[Stress]
-Eeyup!
[Laughs] Eeyoop! Nope, nothing yet.
Okay... Maybe
[Momiplier stresses]
Maybe she snuck over there.
-[Sudden bravery] No, she's scared of Momma.
-Momiplier's so scary.
Oh yeah...
-Oh you don't wanna mess with me.
No, but what about y'know... Freddy was- Freddy was on the move
Y'know you might wanna look out on that...
-5! Oooh!
Wait, hit your flashlight
-OOOO!
Hit- okay!
[Momiplier stresses]
What about to the right?
No wait!
-Oh what, what, what?!
[Lots of panic. Lots.]
Put it down! Move your mouse to the right! Hit that light.
[Screaming]
Now, check that hallway! Flashlight! Hit Ctrl!
NO NOT THAT ONE!
[Screams then laughs]
What did you do? Ctrl! AHH! FREDDY!
[Momiplier screaming noises]
PUT THAT DOWN
STAY. Don't move.
Don't move!
-Sshh!
[Simultaneous shushing]
[whispers] Okay
-Don't even breathe!
Alright, now your music box! Your music box!
[Momiplier screams]
Put the mask up!
[Momiplier continues to scream]
[Panic ensues]
[Screaming]
-Oh! I'm okay! I'm okay! :D
-Ohh I'm still alive!
[Mark relaxes]
-It's a miracle!
Okay, wait no, take it, take it down.
[Freddy jumpscare]
[Momiplier laughs]
It's a miracle! -_-
-At least, at least he was kinda cute~
Yeah that was kinda cute.
-9, um you're still there. Ugh, GOOD BOY.
Good boy!
-Good boy!
-I always tell my dog: GOOD BOY!
You keep that music box wound up.
-Good girl!
Yeah you never want to get behind on that.
You can stay on top if-
-3 AM! I think I'm gonna make it!
[Mark claps] Yay!
-Come oonn!!!
You can do this.
-I'm watching ya!
Oh I'm watching ya.
-Oh! ... It's gone!
Uh oh
-I'm in trouble.
Where'd they go?
Maybe they went to camera 2...
You think that maybe they went to camera 2?
-I don't think so.
-10!
Wait, turn on your flashlight on camera-
-1!
Did you see?
-Uh, what, what, what?!
Go back to 10!
-10! 10!
10!
-Oh! Eugh...
Ah!
-BONNIE!
Alright, now your music box.
-What should I do?!
Music box!
-Oh wind up!
[Panic]
-Okay I'm winding the music. Come on 3 AM! Come on, come on.
See? Yeah.
-Where was it? 9? No..
No, wait, where, where's Chica?
-10! Oh ah 4!
-Oh, she's gone. 7! Yeaahh.
Okay where's Bonnie?
-Bonnie? 2! No... 9?
-It's 3? 8? Oh I'm in, I'm in trouble. Uh oh.
-I'm in deep...
You need the light switched-
[Bonnie jumpscare]
...It was a good effort.
It was a good effort.
-That's disappointing. :(
-[words unknown]
-[Gasps] Something is wrong here.
-Some- I don't like the MMM sound!
[Mark laughs]
-I hear ya! I hear ya... OKAY. I see.
Uh oh! Uh oh, they're finally out and about, okay alright.
-Let's see who's gonna win here?
-I'm not gonna let you win.
-3 AM, 3 AM
Alright
-Okay, I need to find you guys!
-HIIII Chica!
One of them
Okay
-Stay there, Chica!
Okay, alright
-Okay still... not there.
-I need to wind up...
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Good job!
Good job, good job, good job.
-Oh, oh, Chica!
You're doing so good.
[Momiplier stress]
-STAY THERE!
But where's...? You gotta find Freddy.
-Freddy? Okay. Oh my god!
-UUUGGGHHH WIND UP!
-9? OOHHHH
-OOOOHH
-OOH
-Oh my god
-[???] Do-don't disapoint me!
-Mommy still...has to win ;o;
Wait, wait, go back to 3.
-Oh yeah!
There!
[Momiplier screams]
Okay, getting close, getting close
-WHAT SHOULD I DO?!
You're fine, turn off the light.
[Momiplier stress]
Okay now, you just gotta make sure they don't get
to camera one and camera two.
[Momiplier holds long note]
'Cause if they get to camera one and camera two
that means they're close.
[Momiplier still holding long note]
Now, you also have to check down the main hallway, so
put the camera- oh actually wind up the music box first
[Momiplier vocalizing]
THEN, once that's wind(wound) up
put the camera down
- AYAYAYAYAYAYA CAMERA DOWN DOWN
-OKAY NOW DOWN
[Momiplier is panicking]
Okay, now put the camera, er, hit the light
Okay no one's in the hallway, right?
Okay, put the camera back up.
Alright, wind up that music box just a little bit. JusT A LIL BIT.
Alright now look in one...
[Simultaneous panic]
PUT IT BACK (x7)
-AH OKAY, 1.
1, is anyone there?
2?
There! Okay, crawling in.
Okay, you keep an eye on that one
Okay, alright
-Now where you going?
Wi-wind up your music box
-Okay, wind up. 5 o'clock! 5 AM! Come on!
Alright, check 2 again.
-My life depends on you guys. Oh come on!
Come on! Put the light-
[Momipliers screams]
Put it down!
Put this down
-NO NO NO NO
PUT IT DOWN
[Momiplier freaking out]
Put the light on!
-OKAY
There! He's coming, don't worry about that.
It's fine, he's not that close yet.
But you gotta keep an eye on him, so
stay here until you have to wind up the music box.
-OKAY
STAY
-5 AM!
Now go wind up the music box!
Wind it up! Wind!
Wind
Now put it, when you put it back down there, turn the flashlight right on
look down that hallway. STARE HIM RIGHT IN THE EYE.
Alright, now check the light on the right- NOO
[PANIC]
CHECK THE LIGHT ON THE LEFT
Keep an eye on that guy. e_e
-COME ON
-COME ON! D:
-Let me win!
-Oh dear god, LET ME WIN!
You're so close!
Come on!
Alright, you're gonna have to check the musi-
-MUSIC BOOOOOX!!!
Wind it!
Aaaannndd... let go!
-LET GO! Okay ;o;
Put it down! PUT IT DOWN
[Momiplier screaming]
Check the light!
[Panic]
Uh wait! NO NO NO NO NO NO
[screaming]
Go right!
NO!!!! STOP PUTTING THAT UP
[screaming]
STOP! GO RIGHT!
GO RIGHT!!!
[screaming]
NOW PUT YOUR MASK O-
UGH
[relief]
[more screaming]
[claps]
[Mark is exhausted]
-You see?
-You see?!
-I won! B)
(look at Mark's face how precious he is)
[claps]
-That was a miracle, a miracle!
You did it! Okay, okay
-I did it! I did it!
Alright, okay, alright
-Oohh I did it!
Woo!
Okay, so!
-That is so exciting.
I know right, you did it! I'm proud of you
-Hey! Anybody want to lose weight, that's the way you have to lose it, cause it's gonna pump your heart rate so fast
you don't have to go run, just play this one for a few minutes. You can lose a lot of calories.
Yeah makes sense.
-Makes sense?
Alright, you ready to play the next game?
-NO
-Do I have to? :c
Yeah :)
-That's too hard!
-This is much fun! Easy for me.
There's another game, though.
[Momiplier resigns to her fate]
Thank you everybody so much for watching.
Thank you, Mom, for joining me on this one.
And, uh, as always
I will see you in the next video!
Buh-bye!
-Buh-Bye! Happy new year!
(Mark we love your mom so much, thanks for having her on another episode. ^^)